everybody to Sunday morning science John
Perry here I'm very excited today about
my guests I have been teaching science
now for since 2012
you know officially you know publicly
before that I was working with
professors at at Oregon State University
and I would help them redesign their
their classes for online use and there's
a bunch of things you can do online that
you can't do in a classroom and vice
versa so that's how I kind of got
started in science teaching science
communication but 2012 was when I
launched stated clearly and I've done a
lot of videos on chemistry I've done a
lot of videos on genetics and most
people don't have any problems with
those those videos but I've done some
videos on evolution and when I started
doing those videos just the hate mail
started pouring in and early on I I
figured that this this really kind of
deep hatred for the science of evolution
and this really really well founded
denial of this science was only possible
because of certain religious doctrines
and I thought that there was something
special about religion that caused
people to be so hateful
about you know new ideas right and yeah
I figured that was special about
religion but a few years back I did a
video about an alien mummy the thumbnail
for this videos as an as a baby alien
mummy alien mummy it's actually just an
aborted fetus that at a really early
stage that's what fetuses look like but
the there was there was an alien mummy
that was promoted by Gaia it's it was
actually just a dead person that had
been modified to look kind of like an
alien and I did a video explaining you
know this is a human showing the anatomy
and explaining how we know that this is
just a human is this really basic
anatomy stuff and I figured that
everyone would would just know this
right away cuz you know you can just
look at the bones in your hand and you
can see the modifications they did to
this mummy and so on it's very
straightforward but that was not the
case I was a little bit rude in that
video
like assuming that this was obvious it
should be obvious to people but I had I
got the most hate mail the most most
death wishes I have ever received and so
I started to realize wow this isn't just
about religion there's something else
going on here there are certain ideas
that people hold on to really strong has
nothing to do with religion there's
something else about human nature that
that video is probably the most hated
video I've ever made it sits here on the
state and casually Channel the recently
I did some videos on viruses and I've
seen the exact same thing there's this
anti-vaccine movement there's this idea
that the viruses is a hoax there's this
idea that the virus is a weapon and
people are absolutely convinced by these
ideas and it is that they have a hatred
towards me when I'm saying that this is
either a the virus is either natural or
it was a people who were studying
viruses it's it is possible that it was
a lab leak that it actually that is
actually still possible and people were
just absolutely enraged by the
possibility this is not a weapon or that
it's not a hoax whatever it is that
their belief about the virus was they
refused to accept anything else and so I
I just kind of woken up to this idea
that you know there's something beside
religion there's something about human
nature that causes this and my guest
today Scott Perry you might notice
there's a there's a name link between he
and I but he was trained in psychology
with a focus on the science of applied
behavior analysis it's sometimes called
behavior engineering behavioral
engineering and early on he worked as a
child psychologist for the Oregon school
system and aside from counseling he
would study the behavior of students
that were causing problems in the
classroom you know and he'd try and
figure out why they were acting out so
what were the triggers what would happen
before the student would act out and
then what would happen afterwards to try
and figure out what was causing this
behavior and a lot of times things that
we think are punishments for students
that are acting out
actually rewards so if you send someone
to the principal's office for example
they might if they're experiencing
social anxiety in the classroom well
they get to go and wait in a quiet room
and then just have one-on-one time with
the principal and that might be super
rewarding for him so that might actually
cause them to do this maybe they're
scared of someone on recess and so if
you hold them in from recess that's
actually a reward not a punishment and
so you'll get a student that's acting
out because of this really really
interesting things that you find when
you actually study you treat a student
as you actually do perform science
you're observing their behavior and so
he would produce these functional
behavior assessments and he would give
advice to the teacher how to change
their behavior when interacting with the
student and also you know this could be
advice it's given to the parents as well
later on he went into school
administration and he applied these
exact same techniques to you know staff
and organizations as a whole and he was
able to come up with with different
recommendations for changing school
structures to to to help with attendance
stop students from dropping out and so
on changed the experience for students
to make it a much more healthy
environment for students to come to and
in place where they would actually
desire to come to and his work has been
used in several states now and changing
how it is that they they interact with
their students and you know help with
these drop out raids during his career
he spent a lot of time teaching people
how to do a simplified version of
behavior analysis and he's come up with
a concept that he calls the ABCs of
human motivation and this has actually
been really helpful for me understanding
what it is that that's driving the kind
of amiss behavior of some of my viewers
right and so oh by the way he's also my
dad Scott Perry welcome dad welcome to
Sunday morning science
yeah yeah so kind of my first question
for you is about the the ABCs of human
motivation and I want to focus on
certainty this concept of certainty that
you that you've really honed in on but
let's first just talk about all three of
them together and just a kind of a brief
overview of how you've used them in your
career people haven't talked about but I
put it together in a way that makes
sense to me and helps explain a lot of
behavior not all behavior but but a lot
of behavior the ABCs a a B and C stand
for adequacy belonging and certainty and
I have found that the desire for
adequacy the desire for belonging and
the desire for certainty are real big
motivators of human behavior yeah the
more you think about it more you look at
the world with those glasses on you know
looking for evidence of adequacy blowing
and certainly as drivers of behavior and
motivators the more you look at it that
way the more you see it's just it's
amazing how many things are motivated by
those three factors it so what do you
mean by by adequacy belonging in
certainty so we're driven to - were
driven to feel adequate we're driven to
feel belonged were driven to feel
certainty yeah so so I believe everybody
has a desire or at least most people
that I know and me myself included we
want to be we don't want to be
inadequate we want to be adequate we
want to be more than adequate we want to
be competent
we want to be good at things we want to
get A's on our paper we want to be we
want to think that we're a good father a
good a good professional a good you know
we're good at things we're competent
so that's adequacy the desire to be
confident feel like you've got something
of value to contribute to the world
right so that's a big motivator the
second one is belonging we want to feel
like we're part of a group part of a
family part of a congregation part of a
club part of a community so that we will
be missed if we're gone we're gonna be
missed
that's the thing that we have and then
the third thing is desire for certainty
a certainty would be financial security
it would be safety it would be
predictability III know what's gonna be
happening to me next week week beyond I
know where I'm going to the food's gonna
come from my shelters and I come from
and then big life questions I know you
know where I came from why I'm here and
where I'm going in life and that relates
to people's religious convictions and
enhance with this desire for certainty
to know and we live we live in a world
that's just full of uncertainty I mean
death this uncertain thing that
everybody faces we live in a world that
has you know time and space uncertainty
when did time began
where does space and I mean there's
there's all kinds of and so people are
longing for a confident sense of
grounded certainty and they I think we
hunger for all three of those things and
I've note that with in my work with kids
that that they they want to have a sense
of adequacy a sense of belonging in a
sense of certainty and the antithesis of
that I call it a pain center as I am
inadequate I don't belong and I'm
uncertain and when we get evidence that
those things
are true i get evidence I'm inadequate I
I really want to do anything I can to
push that away
yeah and figure out so and that's where
I first noticed it with with kids that
have behavior problems like on the
playground they yeah they in trouble
they hit somebody they do all these
behaviors and then when when confronted
about it they were immediately blame
everybody else but everybody else is at
fault it's not me and I thought boy this
is a unique characteristic of kids that
have behavior problems at school as they
blame everybody else but then I remember
real distinctly driving driving one
morning I was late for a meeting it was
an early morning meeting at the high
school I was driving and going through a
residential area and going fast yeah and
I saw blue lights in my rear view mirror
and I realized I was being pulled over I
immediately started to try to figure out
why this wasn't my fault why this
policeman was sitting here eating Donuts
waiting for a law-abiding taxpaying
citizen to come along and you know I was
I was portraying myself as a victim with
my own head and that's a way acting my
own sense of adequacy yeah if I have
choice between I'm a rotten person and
the world's not in place to be
I'm going to choose the world's a rotten
place to be and I'm okay it's just it's
a natural thing protecting my sense of
adequacy the same thing with bombing if
I don't belong that creates an enormous
pain when I first really became aware of
that personally was at a wedding that I
was at broomis Minh which meant I stood
in line at the wedding and that kind of
thing but at the reception I was I knew
the groom but I didn't know anybody else
and everybody else knew each other right
I was walking around this wedding
reception not knowing anybody except the
groom and he was really busy so I didn't
have time to
and I just didn't belong in assistants
it's a painful thing did not belong so
that's only if that's the only time
you've not belonged a wonderful life
belonging is a huge motor that you know
starting in the elementary school and
middle school and middle school it's
more important you sit next to them what
you know or anything else it's like the
social groups and then you know as we
get older we become part of different
communities and groups and you can see
the power of belonging
the motivator games are you know it's a
belonging issue political parties
countries allegiance to countries it's
this desire to belong so anyway ABCs are
big motivators and you wanted to I know
focus on certain oh yeah yeah well I
mean all of these kind of overlap right
because you've got you know so one of
the things I was thinking about when
when you were saying you know we have
these these drives
I just think about different rituals
that we have so we have marriages for
example which gives you certainty that
your partner you know give you you put a
ring on and you give each other
certainty that you're there for each
other that's also a sense of belonging
and you know also people people who are
not married in a culture that puts high
emphasis on marriage they feel
inadequate so kind of all of those
things are linked into these rituals but
really I think there's a lot of
certainty involved with that ritual the
religion tells you what's going to
happen after you die which gives you
certainty and I mean gives you a
belonging to you're gonna belong in some
new club after you die right
so anything that would challenge the
belonging that you have built for
yourself the adequacy that you built for
yourself the certainty that you built
for yourself is going to be jarring
right so yeah the the theory of
evolution kind of attacks all three of
those
you are a pastor teaching that the earth
is 6,000 years old right
so you're the community you belong to
your adequacy as a teacher in that
community and then your certainty of
what it is that you are like all of
those things are challenged if if you
believed and have been teaching young
Earth Creationism your entire life and
and I think you know that it seems that
people now are building these groups
online around believing in aliens
believing in conspiracy theories and so
on I remember when I during September
11th I was actually at a friend's house
we were supposed to go hiking that day I
was I was in high school and we woke up
early and we're gonna go on this hike
and I was at her house I was picking her
up and then sometimes that the towers
got smashed into and so we ended of just
watching TV all day with her dad and he
had he knew who it was he had all these
ideas about who it was and how the
government was doing this and that
already he had he had worked out this is
really strong sense of adequacy that he
had in his armchair about what he knew
was happening and it was just so bizarre
to me but this was this was the thing
that he did to to feel good there's all
these different groups online there's
have you heard of the in cell movement
though involuntary and involuntarily
celibate there was a there was a
movement that started out a very helpful
productive movement in the beginning
where people who were in who were
celibate for reasons that you know
because they couldn't find a mate or
they had a disability or something they
would talk about it online in these chat
rooms and then it ended up turning into
a now it's kind of turned into a hating
of women thing where they'll have
they'll they'll show videos of murders
and stuff like that and just there's a
it's interesting psychologically what's
going on there because people have been
rejected so they didn't have a belonging
and they found this second group that
accepts them for being rejected and it's
it's turned very very toxic but it's
it's really interesting to see what how
this how these things kind of play out
in the world it is said they they they
accept them for being rejected right now
I think that actually happens a lot
where where people feel accepted into a
group of other people that have all been
rejected I've seen that in schools with
kids who have behavior challenges they
belong together right now and kids that
have that the whole system is up against
it's like us you know we're all gonna
wear our black jackets and we're going
to sit in one section of the cafeteria
and all of a sudden there's a whole new
suit little salt structural order
amongst them right and you know adequate
and they feel a sense of belonging in
that rejected group and then they can
kind of redefine what adequacy is and
what belonging is within their subgroup
yeah yeah that I I wanted to make sure
that we talked about your when you were
in college kind of went you know before
you really developed the before year but
you were really seeing these patterns so
clearly you actually started out your
career kind of as a debunker and I
didn't know this until we were talking
about doing this podcast a few days ago
really so you started out your career in
college you were you were doing you were
critiquing a guy's research who had
actually kind of fallen into this trap
of certainty and I'm curious if you can
give us an overview of what that was all
about what you found with that yeah well
well when you get your master's degree
sometimes you have to do a master's
thesis or a project and I I picked I
can't remember how I came across it
dr. Harold Levinson who had come up with
this notion that if children have
trouble reading you can you can cure the
reading problem if you will by giving
them in motion sickness medication yeah
if they most it will help them read more
smoothly see the letters get the sounds
etc and I saw his book and it struck me
as curious that we had been trained to
do what they call double-blind research
where the researcher you know you got
two groups subjects one receives the
treatment the other does not receive the
treatment but the researcher doesn't
know which group is which until at the
very end when the results are tabulated
and then you reveal who is in which
group and you see if there were
differences and that avoids things like
experimenter bias and those kinds of
things that can they can sway research
and it was curious to me that this guy
didn't have any I couldn't find any
double-blind studies and backing him up
he was claiming that anti motion
sickness medication fixed reading
disability yeah and though it's actually
interesting because this is this is
probably one of the easiest things to
test because you've got a pill and so
you can easily just make a fake pill it
looks the same they I mean there's a lot
of things that's where it's hard to do
double-blind studies if you like a
certain type of therapy versus a
different type of therapy those are
really hard because you can't really do
a double-blind right the the patient and
the doctor both know if the therapy is
completely different but this is a pill
and a reading test it should be the
easiest possible thing to figure out if
motion sickness medication works and I
think like in theory motion sickness
could work I mean there's no reason to
say that it shouldn't but all yes all
you have to do is test it right I
thought it was a it would be a great
thing if it did work but I just want to
do too
to test it and so for my master's
project I found a group of students that
had reading disabilities yeah I and
asked for a Oregon I found a
pediatrician who is willing to work with
me
got parent permissions and got this
group of students divided them in half
somebody else knew which which students
were in which group I did not know yeah
a placebo pill that looked identical to
the meclizine no it's the anti motion
sickness medication we gave them the put
him on the medication under the doctor's
supervision I gave them a pretest with
the woodcock-johnson reading mastery
test for me and then I used for me as a
post-test several months later and then
looked at the differences in reading
scores and reading fluency there was
just there several different reading
measures that you know that and I
essentially found that there was no
difference between the two groups yeah
and and then of course in my study I
poked holes in my own process I did I
had a fairly small sample size 14 kids
total so that was a small group and it's
difficult to get a good statistical
analysis on and you know that it's
reliable and valid and we've got small
so I suggested that larger studies be
done replicating my process and I think
other studies were done and I didn't
really follow it a lot after I finished
my project because I got so involved
from full-time work and family and
everything you know yeah but I did find
that other people had done double-blind
fairly big double-blind studies and yeah
yeah so here was a guy that and I also
had read since a couple things from him
where he is really
trashing double-blind studies yeah yeah
trying to find ways to explain away the
double
studies and how they're biased and it's
some real convoluted thinking but I
think here's a guy who based his career
on locked into this idea had some
experiences that the testimonials coming
back and I probably a lot of them is
maybe possible effect I don't know but
then you know unless you establish your
your your path your sense of adequacy as
a professional is based on this you get
locked into viewing the world in a
certain way and then he it's really
interesting how he tried to explain away
what we know to be really scientifically
sound processes like double-blind
studies that can ya know once and for
all whether it's accurate or not yeah
this this is super interesting because I
he's got a website he has a YouTube
channel he has a clinic so he's he
actually spent his entire career I he's
probably getting close to retiring now
or he is he is retired but his clinic is
still running and so he still treats
kids for reading disabilities with
motion sickness pills and he's been
doing that for 30 plus years and he it's
yeah it's amazing he has a blog on how
scientists are so bad at what they do he
says that he's the only one who's
figured this out but everyone's teaching
it wrong everyone that understands the
brain wrong except for him and just the
most amazing thing is if you are a drug
company and you make motion sickness
pills the one thing that a drug company
wants likes better than creating a new
drug is finding a new use for a drug
that they already have a have have been
making and have it can get a patent on
for a new use that is the absolute best
thing that can do is if motion sickness
pills could cure dyslexia that would be
absolutely amazing I mean the the and
and the the company that makes these
pills would be paying millions of
dollars to have those trials happen and
get FDA approval for this new second use
so there's it's it's really spectacular
that
he's gone down this route and he's stuck
with that his whole career and it's I I
imagine he's probably convinced I don't
think he's just lying to people I think
he's convinced himself because of the
the testimonials a he if you work with a
hundred kids you're gonna have four that
that improve when during the time that
you're working with them you're gonna
have you're gonna have these
testimonials so he had in response to
the lack of double-blind studies he
published a paper with four case studies
of students that were helped so and
that's out of hundreds of people that
he's treated so it's it's really weird
that he's he's falling into this trap
and it it's interesting because this is
this is not religion based this is not
it's it's he is a trained scientist he
should know better he he just as as has
blinded himself to seeing this and I
kind of makes me wonder how many how
many times I'm blinded by you know my
desire for certainty and adequacy and so
on and we actually we see this a lot in
an online debates of someone if someone
had had said something in a fate in a
facebook fight they will oftentimes
double down when they're shown that it's
not correct because they've got a live
audience and so there's there's a
belonging tug for them there's an
adequacy tug for them and there's a
certainty tug for them when they're
absolute they're performing on Facebook
to to argue something so John and let
I'm glad you talked about you wonder
about yourself because I will I have I
have empathy for dr. Levenson I have
empathy for those people that are on
Facebook because I'm subject to the same
desire for certainty for belonging for
adequacy
I recognize that those things drive me
and over the course of life I develop
paradigms that help me explain the world
and help me understand help me
feel a sense of belonging and a sense of
certainty within my world and once I get
those things and I start to feel
comfortable and live within that skin it
gets I start to develop blinders without
even realizing it and to where I don't
want to see information that's contrary
to my paradigm it's it's and and it
takes some real effort and psychological
strength and self-awareness to burn
those blinders and allow new information
to come in whether it's you know
scientific information or any kind of
evidence that I haven't considered that
would cause me to change my opinion and
you know I think this is in relation to
scientific understandings it's in
relation to political views your view of
who you are in the universe and in your
relationship with God if there is a God
and if you believe there's not a god are
you open to evidence that there might be
a God that comes down the road are you
gonna stay open the battery it's it's
like those blinders that creep up on all
of us all the time and there's a really
funny story and I'm forgetting
everybody's names and I'm forgetting the
names of the species too but in in
paleontology for a long time we thought
that whales were related to this it's
kind of like a wolf-like group of
animals and genetics was showing us that
they were actually more closely related
to things like cattle and hippos and
stuff like that and it was that there
were there were certain clues from the
teeth that were suggesting that they
might be related to this this wolf like
species and this wolf like group of
species and paleontologists had had made
you know museums with this in there you
know this is where we think the link
might be and one of the guys who had had
had done that he was a paleontologist he
made it he made an exhibit and
everything he said that he found an
ankle bone to one of the early things
that we knew was a whale ancestor and it
had a hippo like ankle bone and he had
he had just spent a bunch of money
putting together this museum exhibit
showing a different connection and he
said he was so angry that he didn't tell
anyone for like a week that he found he
found evidence against his own theory
and that really just debunked his his
the the connection that he had put there
yeah he was so angry that he just he
wouldn't tell anyone for a week and he's
okay I gotta tell everybody and and now
it's that was this that was this big
final blow in that that debunking the
the link there but when he finally did
tell everybody I just said good for him
I mean that take courage and strength to
be able to allow new information in and
and I think that's something we ought to
be celebrating would we see it as people
that are willing to change their opinion
in the face of new evidence and not just
hunker down because that takes some
charity and some psychological strength
to do that yeah yeah yeah it's it
science is a lot of times people say
that science progresses funeral by
funeral because even scientists have
trouble doing this right so someone
someone who gained status in a field and
then it's hard to say anything against
them because they you you see this even
in science you see this this the
stickiness of ideas even bad ideas
sometimes but yeah it is really
refreshing to see someone who like in
his case where he actually was the one
who debunked his his his pet theory
right Oh what was the science progresses
funeral by funeral right hey Freddie got
security yeah but yeah because it has
somebody
has to die so that other people can do a
modification of what they were believing
and do it safely
yeah it's especially true with a new
field or a field that's not well
developed yet because it's personality
is almost more important than anything
when when all of what all the competing
theories in a field are are pretty
they're built on a fairly weak
foundation of evidence you have
personality that wins out eventually
you'll have evidence when evidence
starts to build up you personality
doesn't matter anymore but a lot of
times so in linguistics this is a big
problem right now with Chomsky like if
people say stuff that are against his
ideas it pretty much doesn't get
published and you'll you will see that
in other fields origin of life was like
that for a while and that's now changed
there's a huge diversity of idea is now
being studied an origin of life but the
that it's that's a big problem the
National Science Foundation found the
best way to get rid of this is to get
start these really large sent research
centers that pull in people from all the
different fields of research to tackle
one problem and when you get up when you
get a bunch of people together it tends
to go away but yeah it's a problem in
science it's a problem everywhere we've
got a couple of questions Mike man asks
I would love to know what your dad
thought about you while you were growing
up with everything he's saying well
that's kind of a broad it's kind of a
broad question but yeah how was it was
it as a parent you know as a kid I
didn't know that that you were a
behavioral engineer were you able to
successfully engineer our behavior as
when we were growing up no no I actually
taught parenting classes right and you
guys were little and I would teach
parenting classes and then
from week to week I'd have to keep
modifying what I was saying because you
guys were we're trashing my my theories
I I remember there's lots of situations
where I mean the the the behavior
strategies were very helpful yeah
in working with you guys but I also I
also would have to say that I think we
we had an interesting family dynamic
when you're young because we were at
that time I was a member of the Mormon
Church and very locked into the Mormon
theology which is rampant with certainty
I mean there's certainty is III believe
that certainty is the currency of that
many religions it's a primary currency
it's like they're offering their
congregation a sense of certainty yeah
where I just super valuable yeah yeah we
should talk about the value of certainty
the value of adequacy belonging and
certainly I think there there's a great
deal of value to all three of those
things for us but so while we were in
this in this religion of certainty I
think that I was also trying to teach
you guys about critical thinking and
about when you see an advertisement on
TV don't take it at face value
ask yourself go deep and I in and all
four of you boys I I really see critical
thinking as a part of what you guys all
do which I really appreciate it and and
all four of us left Mormonism
independently yeah yeah all of your kids
left Mormonism you left Mormonism
eventually I think I think in a lot of
part because you were teaching us to
think critically when we were kids and
but I I do find it interesting that you
were
you you had an actual research program
debunking a guy's conclusions with this
very careful research while
simultaneously believing that Joseph
Smith got golden plates from a Native
American who was resurrected from the
dead it's like the the amount of
partitioning that we can do in our heads
you know is pretty astonishing yeah you
know I've given that one some thought
because it's it's almost it almost backs
up to the question can you be a
critically thinking deep thinking
research based person and believe in God
also and if you believe in the Bible and
Mormon Church there's Joseph Smith in
the golden plates and all the race thing
but the Bible you've also got some some
stories that are kind of far-fetched if
you think about them in terms of whether
it's Noah's Ark and the flood or or or
Jesus Christ and the resurrection man I
mean there's a there's a lot of things
that that scientifically in our world
with our senses don't match up and so
you know some people reject all of those
things and only trust what they could
see some people have a religious belief
in terms of and I know you've addressed
this on some of your other shows around
supernatural supernatural forces and
scientific forces and and one of the
things I've been mired about you John is
your your willingness to look at
evolution and religious belief at the
same time and how they can potentially
be compatible and I don't know where I'm
going with that but I think that that
was a
in our family there was that that kind
of balance between yeah we've got this
religion that holds these things on a
grand scale but we've also got to be
doing critical thinking at the same time
I'm still later I'm not a Mormon but I I
do still believe and I've got a belief
in God and I've got a mom I'm trying to
hold to this whole notion of critical
thinking and balance those but for me
part of my critical thinking is
recognizing how many things I don't yet
understand about this universe and I
think that leads me to my faith well at
the same time I'm wanting to to gather
evidence I I heard a phrase the other
day that I really like it said in god we
trust'
everyone else bring data yeah and I
really think that that idea that I trust
in God but everybody else I need to see
your data so the with Mormonism is
especially interesting because there's a
bunch of claims that Mormonism makes
that are directly testable like the Book
of Mormon claims to be a record of
Native American history but it they've
got swords they've got horses and
chariots they've got all sorts of things
that there is zero evidence that existed
those things existed in Native American
culture before contact with Europeans
and I mean they're just they're just
mountains of this evidence that you can
actually study it the Mormon Church they
oh yeah the Mormon Church had actually
tried to find archaeological evidence
they were spending a lot of money at
this on this at one time to try and find
archaeological evidence to support that
the idea that the Book of Mormon is an
actual history and I just led nowhere so
all these things we could have just we
could have we could have set up the
double-blind study right we could have
we could have figured this out but but
you could orbit apologists who do a
really amazing
job at trying to justify all those
things with with some pretty highfalutin
language and I mean when people have
their sense of certainty challenged yeah
for the great lengths to defend it and
and that's not just what Mormonism
that's everywhere well that's like your
guy who has a blog about bad science
when he is the definition of a bad
scientist he's doing you know he's he's
fallen for his own bad hypothesis and
he's he's now saying that the world was
attacking him he's he's the one who
knows the truth it's very similar when
you go on to these the Mormon apologetic
websites they're doing the same thing as
this guy they're they're taking really
obvious evidence and finding ways to
dismiss it that that are really really
bad like it if you're in if you're in it
it almost seems like enough to dismiss
the evidence against your belief but as
soon as you just try and look at this
objectively it's super clear that
they're just coming up with really
desperate excuses to explain away why
there is no evidence for the claim that
they're they're claiming that they have
I think with and joy in our discussion
every time we say they I want at least
one finger pointing back to myself yeah
because these same dynamics are going
through me all the time I don't have
it's it's not that I'm sitting
comfortably as a judge of all these all
these people that are having trouble
with their adequacy belonging
uncertainty I do too
so it's just it's important for us to
all recognize where we're all in this
right
I'll ABC ship right and one of the
things that we can be fairly certain of
is that certainty is is not real right
we can be certain that certainty is a
myth right so the I think in general is
just so chaotic
our societies are so chaotic then you
know the certainty you have in your
marriage a certain do you have and
everything like it's it's not fully real
and but but you put this as one of our
three strongest drives and so there must
be something about certainty that gives
us an evolutionary advantage if we've
evolved to be so chasing after sorry all
the time there must be something to it
right I thought about the evolutionary
advantage of all three of those things
adequacy belong certainty and it makes
sense from an evolutionary point of view
that we would be reinforced for striving
for a sense of adequacy a striving for a
sense of competence because those who
are competent are going to be more
likely to survive over time and so we
get this pride for confidence strive for
belonging because within with belonging
comes come safety right increased
efficiency you know if you're part of
the group you're able to attack a
problem a mammoth or you know whatever
the issue able to you're able to do
something as a group much more
powerfully than if you do it by yourself
so there's an evolutionary advantage to
that and certainty in an uncertain world
I believe that certainly there's
enormous power uncertainty certainty if
you if you have a sense of certainty it
gives you a focus you're able to focus
you've got you've got specific goals
that you're moving toward with
confidence if you're confident urine
you're attractive in this society and
that's because of people's longing for
certainty so there's a lot of advantages
to to certain be if somebody is
uncertain and everything they do because
they're not sure if it's accurate and
they're waiting for more data to confirm
it etc etc a lot of times they'll be
frozen in inaction yeah they won't they
won't move
they won't get off the die but if
they've got certainty and that sense of
confidence about the future I know where
I'm going and I know what's coming next
there's there's a lot of power and that
I I used to love the when I watched
Mohammad Ali love you yeah yeah a lot
about he's that he amazing he would oh I
am the greatest yeah
he had this sense of absolute certainty
and he wasn't allowing he had blinders
on he was choosing to have blinders on
he was not going to pay attention to any
data that suggested that he wasn't the
greatest and that gave a lot of power
and getting to reaching this goal yeah
yeah yeah definitely in sports having
certainty that you are the winner is I
mean people that's why people in sports
are so superstitious a lot of times
because that that helps you gain
certainty the watching his fights
there's there's a really cool
compilation of his knockouts on YouTube
and it's funny he was such a good
athlete that in in some of the videos
you know this is TV and what was it the
80s or the 70s TV couldn't refresh fast
enough to catch some of his punches
there were there were fights that he did
where people thought that it was a fake
knockout it was like a you know you know
maybe he got paid off or someone got
paid off to fall and it's because he was
punching so fast that you couldn't see
him hit it's amazing yeah he was he was
really good and very very very cocky and
I think yeah that was a big part of its
a big part of how he intimidated his
rivals to kind of throw them off a
little bit and it was super successful
we see this in politicians as well we
see this in see this in in business
leaders so it absolutely a politician
who stands up and says I'm not sure
about this but you know I mean I'm gonna
get the votes the politician who stands
up and says I know where we're headed I
know what the future holds and
follow me yeah absolutely we want to
follow that because it gives us all the
senses sir
and this is one of the things that you
know as if you're if you're a parent and
your child has dyslexia and you meet
this doctor who says that he knows he's
the only one who knows how to cure this
and it sits with this medication and
then you read a paper debunking it who
says that says but further research
needs to be done that's the
responsibility of a good scientist to
explain what the weaknesses are of a
study but that's not what he's doing
he's saying no this will cure your child
and the parent is saying oh you're gonna
cure my child there's there's a there's
a an asymmetry when it comes to science
versus conspiracy theory and this is
medicine versus alternative medicine
fake medicine there's this asymmetry in
that there's a couple of asymmetries
especially in medicine first of all your
doctor will tell you when he can't cure
you
hopefully he or she will tell you when
they can't carry you when there's not a
treatment for your disease as pseudo
scientists will say oh I can carry you
for that so there's an asymmetry there
that the the mainstream Medical
Institute keeps track of their successes
and failures the person selling you a
faulty drug isn't going to tell you all
of all the failures that have been
happening so you just you don't have
this accumulation of failures to look at
and then of course there's there's that
that difference in certainty and and all
of this feeds into the belief and
conspiracy and alternative medicines
that don't actually work and thinking
that they're better than real medicines
and so there's there's all of these
things going against the people who want
to be accurate and show the uncertainty
that exists they get they get they get
punished for for for being honest about
this which is I don't know how the heck
we're supposed to deal with this is just
a huge problem this asymmetry and in in
being honest
really
that's interesting or oftentimes we were
punished for acknowledging our lack of
certainty so we're reinforced for
appearing to be certain even when we're
not man yeah that then that is a problem
tell celebrating uncertainty celebrating
those who are willing to acknowledge
that their theory may have flaws in it
or that there may be other data that
needs to be looked at we're not in the
habit of celebrating those kinds of
admissions because that's not what we're
hungry for we're hungry for for a sense
of certain and sometimes you know I was
thinking about conspiracy theories and
and first of all there have been
conspiracies in the world and so
everything's not necessarily a false
conspiracy theory right sometimes there
are conspiracies that happen but as I
worked with people over the course of my
life and you know mostly students and
schools and that kind of thing but I
noticed that there are a lot of folks
who especially folks that are in pain
and dealing with their own sense of
inadequacy they are looking for
something to blame that on that is not
themselves right they're trying to pick
that pain center from going off they
don't want to feel a sense of inadequacy
so they're looking outside themselves
and a convenient target for that often
is the government if I'm not being
successful in making a living and
providing for my family if I billing for
it and if I have a few negative
experiences with some government
entities I can start to look at the
government or the church or is some
organization out there especially a
nameless organization
that is at fault for this and I can
start to get angered into that and I
think at least for some folks that's
where the thirst for conspiracy theories
about and the interest in that is born
out of it's born out of this desire that
something outside of me is responsible
for a lot of the misery that I
experienced in my life and partly it's
because I don't want to acknowledge that
my choices over time have also
contributed to the misery that I met
where this guy knowledge yeah where this
gets really difficult is when there
really is some sort of a force working
against you and you can't a that the the
line is so blurred between what what is
your fault what is something that you
can change versus what is this thing so
my my ex-girlfriend Vernie 'she had
narcolepsy and she she would talk about
this all the time she she has narcolepsy
which makes you sleepy and she had
cataplexy as well and it's the super
vague disability and that other people
can't see it it's not like you're
missing an arm right
and it's even vague to her because
people get sleepy anyways and people
people procrastinate they don't you know
so she had this difficulty figuring out
when to be hard on herself or something
versus when to blame it on the
disability and then you know it's also a
disability it's not easily treatable
with with medications so that was like
it was it was really interesting having
conversations with her about that and
you know we we have these these types of
things all the time like if if your boss
doesn't like you and that's why you
think you're not getting a raise it's
really easy to think that well that's
the only reason you're not getting a
raise or that's the only reason why
you're not making it that you're
advancing is because someone or some
group of people are out to get you at
work and it becomes really difficult so
it
I really admire the struggle that you
said viremia engaged in and that was
figuring out what was her responsibility
and what responsibility belong to some
other entity out there right and that's
really valuable work my wife Patty it
one of the phrases that she's always
asking herself which I really appreciate
is Who am I in the matter so when
there's a problem going on she asked
first
Who am I in matter what was my
contribution to this and there may be
other factors and Rabia that maybe that
the government it may be that DMV is
doing this thing to me or maybe that the
bank has done this it may be that there
are other entities that have
responsibility for some of this angst
that I'm going through and I have
responsibilities too and I'm going to
work at figuring out what's my part and
what part belongs elsewhere and what can
I do something about and I when I see
people going through that kind of
thinking I just want to stand up and
cheer because that is that that's the
work of real integrity to me yeah yeah
yeah I mean it was it that is really
important because it gets so easy to be
bitter or to think that you're just
disabled or you're oppressed or and and
that there's nothing you can do about it
I mean obviously sometimes there is
nothing you do about you actually be you
know and in some cases her disability
was really stopping her from doing
things that she wanted to do and there
was there's just nothing she can do
about it we we do not know how to treat
this disease properly but the trying to
figure that out is it's a real
frustration for people typically the
responses that I see from from people
are I'm right you're wrong you are an
idiot
grow up you know whatever whatever it is
it's like I am completely correct in my
opinion and I'm going to attack your
sense of adequacy you are completely
incorrect and the response usually is
the other person attacking my attic I
mean it's this back and forth attacks on
one's adequacy without a willingness to
say you know I agree with this part in
this part of what you're saying I also
hold this part I mean real conversation
real balance patient often doesn't have
it's it's this polarization where people
aren't assuming responsibility for
themselves they're just really looking
to attack somebody else's sense of
adequacy yeah and I feel like that's
magnified on the internet which is
unfortunate now because we're all locked
in our houses for the most part like
from her because personal one-on-one it
doesn't happen like I I I teach I teach
evolution on the internet and I used to
do a lot of visiting in classrooms and
the experience is way different when a
student is upset with it they'll bring
up their issue but you can you can
they're not angry or they're not they're
not giving you death wishes and telling
you're gonna burn in hell they're
they're asking you questions and they
respect you as a humans for some reason
when they're talking to you in person
but not when they're talking to you on
the internet and it's a interesting why
that happens and there's a certain
there's a certain kind of it's kind of a
combination of the the road rage that
happens where you're you're locked off
in this on your own little box so you
feel safe you can say whatever you want
but also you've got your on display and
so you can't if you back down then
you're certain your your adequacy is
diminished right publicly diminished so
it's there's a lot of things that play
there I want to for people who have
questions specifically about the the
adequacy blowing certainty specifically
about
behavioral engineering which is kind of
a term that sounds almost evil but I can
be used for good and evil like like any
like any any other thing that works yeah
it sounds almost like your I mean you
can do that but you can really you can
you can use it to change I think I think
behavioral engineering I was looking up
I was looking at the history of the of
the field and it was originally called
behavioral engineering I think they they
kind of changed that because people
didn't sounded too ominous but that is
that is how you know you know ionization
engineer do try to engineer our behavior
and it's it's for good or for bad
students in middle school in high school
I found that one of the most effective
ways of health and with behavior was
literally to help them see the
connection between their choices and
their consequences yeah big because they
had blinders on they did not want to see
that connection they wanted to believe
everything on somebody else when in fact
their choices were resulting in a lot of
the misery that they were experiencing
you know I I would I'm suspended or I'm
I'm I'm in tied out or what at whatever
experience I'm having that is a result
of the choices that I made leading up to
it but they don't see that they see
themselves as being victimized so a lot
of times my work with them was in
conversation as saying having them talk
through you know if you make this choice
what's going to happen if you make this
choice what's going to happen positive
choices negative choices what will
happen and so helping them as opposed to
figuring out ways of behaviorally
manipulating them with rewards and
punishments it was really for about how
to engage their own thinking so that
they started to recognize the connection
between choices and calm
and started making more pro-social
choices that we result in in them
actually getting what they wanted
ultimately so there was a lot more of
that than there was of kind of a
behavior manipulation I would say so as
opposed to behavioral engineering I
think maybe the better term would be
behavior management and you know helping
kids with with cognitive processes that
help them make better choices yeah a
more more socially acceptable choices
yeah well there when I was earlier on in
my career I was I was doing graphic
design and I spent a lot of times
reading up on web design and how to get
people to do certain you're definitely
doing you're you doing behavioral
engineering when you're designing a web
site when you're designing a user
interface you want you want the person
to do the thing that you want them to do
and you want to make that easy you have
this with recycling we it used to be
that we would just try and make people
recycle by making them feel guilty and
then the city started making the recycle
box bigger than the garbage can and
there's a bunch of little things that
are being done there so I think it there
are there are when you do this analysis
on a large scale it is it really is its
behavioral engineering you if you're if
you're a good behavioral engineer right
you're trying to get people to do things
that they would want to do anyways just
making it easier but certainly you know
Facebook is engineering their their
website to keep you on there as long as
as long as possible that's usually not
good for the user you get these
addictive problems you have there are
lots of ways that this can be used
against us right I've got a couple of
questions here how did religion evolve
from caveman paintings to some do
something that billions believe I think
I think I think religion or believing in
stories to explain how things came to be
whether or not there's evidence behind
those stories
that's just been something that has
always been important we've always
wanted I think maybe I mean you could
you could describe it in the terms of
adequacy and certainty people have been
wanting adequacy so they tell stories
and they've been wanting certainty so
they believe stories I don't know what
are your thoughts on that it that makes
sense to me that you know we find
ourselves plunked down in a world where
there's a lot of uncertainty there's a
lot of danger and there's a lot of
questions that we don't have answers to
we see this ball of fire in the sky we
see people be born we see people die we
recognize that's gonna help happen to us
and we feel uncertain we feel this sense
of an angst and so we're looking for an
answer what can explain this oh it's a
hunger that people have naturally and so
if somebody stands up and says I know
the answer it's this and they're
confident and they and they have
charisma well we want to subscribe you
know and that eases our anxiety and we
start to go in that direction and then
if somebody else stands up and says no
the answer is over this way that creates
uncertainty for us and so we want to get
blinders to that because we're already
comfortable with this direction and I
think that that is a dynamic that
happens this constant yeah there's
something else that's really interesting
about mythology is that we have it's
almost seems like we have to personify
concepts to really start to think about
them I keep talking about this book I'm
reading on the Black Plague but people
had everybody thought that the disease
was caused by an entity so a lot of
people thought it was caused by God but
people who weren't religious would think
it was caused by a demon
there was there was they would even
ascribe the demon they knew what it
looked like there's a bunch of different
descriptions some thought was caused by
this woman who wore a certain type of
clothes and had a certain type of face
and there was a lady who got arrested
for dressing up like that and scaring
people and she was disturbing the peace
so that there's who said we have to
personify in this case a disease to
really think about it we're so bad at it
so think about think of it the the the
Romans had God's for war there was a god
of war there who would personify courage
and ruthless conquering right you had a
god of there was gods of love that you
had different gods for these different
traits and it would help you study that
virtue right and I think that's really
interesting that that we've seen to have
to do that so I think that yeah there's
a lot of things involved and why humans
are religious but it's there's there is
a study of this and and how it is that
really tells what X because God wants us
to be yeah yeah yeah I said put I
suppose that's that's one one way you
can think of it there's there's a the
counter to that of course to be which
God right is it is it Seuss or is it the
God of War or is it my it's money so
that was an interesting question there
how can how can the NIH engineer the
behavior of Americans to wear masks so
this is actually a question that's come
up several times the comments sorry I
didn't get to it earlier but there's
this insane division about mask wearing
some people are just so much against it
and maybe it could you could you explain
why people are so against it I mean it
is is is this adequacy blowing certainty
we don't want to over apply something to
just everything because we have these
three words now but like is there is
there anything you're seeing here that
might be driving that I think I think it
probably does
well just to preface that I really like
that you said adequacy belonging and
certainly doesn't it's not the be-all
end-all of motivators there's a lot of
things that motivate people
these are just three constructs that
have been useful to me over time that
help explain a lot of things but they
don't explain everything that the
general sense I get with the mask thing
is some people don't want to be told
what to do
at all and I don't want to be told to
wear a mask in public I don't think that
the government Big Brother
and again that's some of that I think
comes from that sense of the government
is responsible for my pain and my
problems therefore I I'm kind of against
Authority against the government some of
it comes from a genuine fear of
government overreach right I mean
absolutely absolutely they take away if
make me wear a mask now you know are
they gonna gradually take away other
rights and right you do other over time
and actually that's the me I seen for my
really for my really hardcore friends on
this on social media this it was it
starts with masks and then was first
they're gonna scare you into wearing
masks so you hide your face then they'll
scare you into taking a vaccines they
can inject a tracker in you then they're
gonna take away your guns
then they're gonna it's people people
have people see this as the start of a
cascade that's going to end in absolute
domination of the of the public which is
interesting that people are taking it
that far because it's a mask to stop you
from spreading a disease and it I don't
I don't understand how the connection is
being made so strongly but it's it's
interesting to see yeah it is and that's
a that's a trigger for folks who who
again ai ai ai
I am adequate in and of myself and to
tell me that I need to change my
behaviors to tell me I'm inadequate in
some way and I run way it starts to get
at my pain center and so I'm going to
project back out and and and push
against you I don't know you know people
that say that if I lose that right then
I'm gonna lose others and it's going to
trip down to all my rights will be taken
away you know I've seen some people
compared to Nazi Germany and Hitler's
view that take away people's rights
incremental II I don't know that there's
a lot of evidence for that in the
current situation and I and I I wear a
mask because I'm I might be a carrier
and not know it and I don't want to give
it to anybody else in this afternoon
we're going to visit our friend Joyce
who's 92 years old and has a number of
underlying health conditions and if I
happen to be a carrier and don't realize
that I don't want to potentially expose
her so I'm going to wear a mask when I
see her we're gonna stay far apart snip
on our Court payback and it's just it to
me it just seems like sensible
precaution right but anyway I 1010
people who don't want to wear a mask
might have ten different reasons
altogether I can't really speak to
although yeah unfortunately I feel like
it's kind of a ballooned out of control
to where there's so much division it's
become it's become a there's there's now
a political divide on the wearing of
masks obviously people on both sides of
the political divide are wearing masks a
lot Ammar but the extreme extreme people
on on the two sides
you know people people on the extreme
left are making it you know their
personal police duty to yell at everyone
they see not wearing a mask which is
kind of it's
like it's reached this this point of
division is it's wobbling out of control
to where it's it's now be just split and
it's it's almost like for some of my
friends that are so far on the right and
against masks they are completely gone
like there's no more reasoning with them
because they're completely severed now
so I don't think that NIH could do
anything to pull those people back in
it's just it's now part of their
identity not wearing a mask is now part
of their identity protesting the wearing
of mass is now up it's a thing they've
said publicly and they're not going to
turn back on it because of it the end
belonging I mean yeah big there other
factors too but that's an example of
where just makes so much sense but if I
lock it something I'm public about it
then my whole sense of identity my sense
of adequacy my sense of the group I
belong to locked in and my blinders go
up and so for me the answer to so much
of this ain't is if individuals would
assume personal responsibility and ask
Who am I in the matter what am i
contributing to this what blinders might
I have up that I need to really take a
solid look at and I'm going to be asking
that question all the time while at the
same time looking at other factors
outside myself that I need to be paying
attention to but I think that we are
psychologically lazy in relation to the
work that it takes to take those
blinders off open up our sense of
potential pain or pain of inadequacy and
acknowledge that you know we need to
look at some additional data it's hard
to do right it's gonna do right I think
it's hard where do you do I'm I got a
question from Ann Smith I thought it was
called behavioral modification because I
was saying behavioral engineering and
yes that there it's been called both and
the
hey mural engineering title has kind of
slipped away for being sounding evil I
think behavior management is the term
that's used more in schools yeah yeah
yeah your management systems of behavior
management it gets away from the notion
that I am engineering you I'm
controlling you I'm I'm here
manipulating you in some way a behavior
management often entails I'm enlisting
you in the process we're talking about
him together were sitting in a circle
and were we're thinking through what's
what's in your best interest what's in
my best interest what's in the best
interest of the school system of the
classrooms but we can all get along and
learn and I engage your thinking in that
and that's a lot different than you know
like a Pavlovian dog I'm going to
reinforce you and give you ticket
rewards or yeah
I got a really interesting question from
Helen Helen Pinkham is white supremacy a
belonging thing you know we're seeing
we're seeing a lot more talk about
racism white supremacy and so on and
then you know just that the history of
colonialism have you thought about this
I don't know have you have you ever
listened to an act like actual self
declared white supremacists and and
seeing what they're talking about you I
listened parenthetically you know I've
seen the white supremacists on the news
that declared them white supremacy but I
haven't like gone to websites and and
studied what they say but it makes sense
to me that's that any group I mean the
factors of that question and thirst for
belonging would be important part for
whether it has to do with white
supremacy or or religious affiliation or
any poetic
affiliation it's it's like that sense of
belonging is important and like you say
all three of these things certainty
adequacy and belonging they're all kind
of intersecting if you were to draw a
Venn diagram there would be a large
intersection where they're kind of
related to each other but I think I
asked that's going on for people who and
subscribe' waspy like the the really
serious white supremacy groups they
maintained a lot of their their
structure in the prison system and there
it's definitely adequacy belonging I
think well one of the interesting things
about the white supremacy at concept is
that your supremacy comes from the color
of your skin that you were born with so
that would make you adequate by default
no matter how poor your choices were in
your life you would have you could fall
back on this sense of adequacy anyways
so I think that has a lot to do with it
but then in the in the prison system I I
know several people who have been to
prison and almost all of them got into
white supremacy groups when they when
they were there and they said that it
was inevitable for they had to either
pretend or they had to actually like
this would start getting indoctrinated
by these ideas because they needed to
feel safe and that's a huge problem we
like something horrible is happening in
our prison systems that needs to be
fixed because that's completely
inappropriate and that and that's what's
feeding this that continue to feed it in
our society to I mean that's one of the
things so that's yeah that is a huge
problem and I think yeah you're right
adequacy adequacy I think is the biggest
thing that I see people clinging to that
idea outside of the prison system it's
no matter how much of a screw-up you are
you're still adequate because of somehow
something that you were born with and
then the belonging seems like a big
pull for it in the prison system I you
know I am just I have to say to that
biases whether it's racial bias
I think another big bias is
attractiveness bias I see that going on
in schools all the time that people that
meet attractiveness criteria get all
kinds of privilege that people that
don't meet those criteria don't receive
socio-economic and disadvantage i I
think there's a lot of a lot of bias
that all of us have and I don't know if
you've heard about the concept of the
implicit bias or yeah bias that I mean
I've got by says I am a white
middle-class male in in society I I
can't even pretend to understand what it
would be like to be a female in this
society to be able to be a person of
color in this society I know what I
experience and I think part of my work
is to try to figure out what what are my
biases and uncover up because I got
blinders on in relation to my own bias
and that's that's also work that's back
to that question of Who am I in the
matter that I think is such a healthy
question for people hold on to you're
talking about attractiveness Marilyn is
my wife she's a nurse and she works with
people who are dying a lot of times and
she's noticed a really big bias within
medicine but to people who are
attractive or particularly people who
who who smell bad there's a bias against
them like the nurses don't want it's
unpleasant to be around them and they
people can actually die because they
stink or because they're ugly or they're
seen as being ugly in the in the medical
system because there's just you just
spend a little bit less time with them
and that adds up with every person
spending a little bit less time with
them and it can be catastrophic so she's
she's paid extra special attention to
what her
when she's driven to get out of the room
quicker with someone she tries to stay
longer
she's like the cute little kids that
come in there everybody gives them so
much attention or the the charming it
could be a charming old guy or a
charming old woman they get so much
attention and then the grumpy old guy or
the the disabled the person with the
it's smells bad or is ugly in some way
they get they get neglected it's it's
just we just do this we do this
automatically and so she's she she
actively fights against that within her
own self which is it's really cool Ted
to hear her talking about this and
trying to do something about it right
can behavioral engineering develop
actual tools to reduce the effect of the
ABC biases I mean something like klo I'm
not sure that is ki alo
which systematizes internet debates oh
that that's a website that it tries to
tries to help with internet debates see
I moderate get rid of some of the
polarity yeah
good things reason can we design a
system that rewards well you were saying
earlier we should reward uncertainty we
should celebrate uncertainty so yeah
that's I the where my mind immediately
goes to his leadership when we have
leaders who are modeling the asking of
the question Who am I in the matter
they are modeling their own willingness
to look at their own biases and they're
willing to look at new data they've got
a sense of kind of a humility while at
the same time a strength of direction
and compassion I've seen that in schools
where you have a superintendent or or a
school principal who really values
those kinds of traits that permeates the
organization when you've got a leader
who's been that kind of thing and and
who is having hard conversations with
people who aren't showing those kinds of
traits so if a society starts to value
that through their leadership then I
think that we can we can make it make a
dent in that if you really polarized in
discussion really quickly and really
heated and say you're in a staff meeting
in school talking about some who's in
school if I as your as your leader and
they take you aside afterwards and talk
to you about that and talk to you about
how I really value mutual respect and a
high high level of trust Patty and I
have done workshops called working to
stop what stops the work and that's
helping helping people understand the
the factors that are at play that shut
down processes and destroy trust within
an organization and a lot of times it's
when people have adequacy belonging and
certainty issues that are running random
and they're they're hijacking processes
in schools and making it unsafe for
people to really have meaningful
dialogue what we found is that in
organizations that have the highest
level of trust especially as exemplified
by the leader then conflict emerges even
more in those organizations but it's
safe conflict it's healthy conflict
people feel like they can express
opposing points of view and do it in a
respectful way in in a way that they're
going to be heard because there's an
environment that is open to and and
willing to accept that kind of dialogue
so yeah I think that I think a lot of
things can can happen yeah but you're
saying one of the easiest like shortcuts
to this is having leaders that value it
leaders evaluate and model it okay in a
democracy where we all want certainty
and so we want to vote for the guy or
gal who declares everything with
certainty are we just like in a feedback
loop of stupidity here or we just kind
of screwed or is there a way out of this
I think that we've seen leaders who have
a sense of certainty a sense of
confidence and a sense of direction and
also can show some humility and who
defer to other expertise when needed and
are open to shifting some policies and
ideas in the face of data I think that's
possible even on a national scale and
and I I think that we've seen leadership
whether they're democratic or Republican
or independent that can exhibit some of
those kinds of characteristics tonight I
I longed for that because I think we're
in a society right now that seems to be
valuing more and more extremes in terms
of they're really looking at certainty
over everything else and I I really hope
we can get to some leaders who really
exemplify this Center well again whether
there are more right-leaning or more
left-leaning but who who exhibit that
confidence that leadership that people
can follow that sense of certainty that
we're all hungry for but at the same
time they do so in a their their servant
leaders and they exhibit some humility
around some of these key points so that
they're modeling for all of us how we
can look at all sides of the question
and not just be polarized
yeah yeah and that would be nice
if we could see that happen another
question are all alien sightings real
there is there have not been any
objectively confirmed alien sightings
that I know of so I would say that
people are seeing something when they
see a UFO but a lot of times it's normal
things maybe maybe one maybe one or two
or several of the sightings actually are
real but nothing's been confirmed in a
way that that we can say that thing that
that person saw is a spaceship from an
alien from another planet there's we
have not found there's no scientific
documentation of extraterrestrials
that's it's you know in mainstream
science for us to study there's no
there's not even any microbes on Mars or
anything that we can we can study for
certain there was there was some some
signs of possible signs of life that
were found in the 70s on Mars but
further studies suggest that that was we
were miss reading the data and this was
they were looking at certain chemistry
that was on Mars and they thought that
only life-forms could generate that
chemistry and then we found out there's
actually a bunch of other things that
can generate that chemistry as well so
we our experiments were designed poorly
and Curiosity rover has some smarter
experiments that it's it's performing
it's looking for the same similar things
like can we find evidence of cellular
metabolism and so on happening on Mars
but there's not been anything solid so
so far as we know we are either alone or
the other life-forms are just hidden
from us to this point but of course you
is how do you know all this stuff I mean
I teach the origin of life I
this is aliens is in my it's in my it's
in my my field here so I've looked at a
lot of ice as your father it makes me
you have a certain sense of pride in you
but I just sometimes you come
with tax and information I think where
does he get all this information I just
pretend that it's a false sense of
certainty I display No oh no the so
there's there's been a lot of
investigations I'm actually really into
UFO stuff and when I when I say this
people think that the people kind of
think that I'm like you know what those
weirdos but I'm really interested in
this stuff in the the different aliens
that people have found because first of
all there's no reason to think that
we're alone like scientifically we
shouldn't think we shouldn't it's like a
50/50 thing as to whether or not we're
alone here there's no evidence right now
there's no good evidence that we are
alone or not alone
and so the when people have these
stories you can't just discount them but
at the same time we know that people
like to we like to personify everything
as I mentioned earlier we've personified
the Black Plague we see beings
everywhere where there were they or not
we just have this instinct to see beings
everywhere so you just keep that in mind
people people hallucinate things people
miss see things all the time and combine
that with the fact that scientific
rigorous science is not finding
life-forms and at least the stuff that's
published and you could say maybe it's
top-secret and sure that's possible
people have kept secret governments have
kept secrets before but it's such a big
secret that it seems really hard to keep
I don't I I would be very surprised if
we've actually successfully kept a
secret contact with another alien
civilization especially an intelligent
civilization let alone microbes or
something but who knows I mean it's it's
certainly possible and there are agents
there's there's a in the news lately
people have been talking about these
UFOs that people see and there's there's
footage of this thing that people claim
as a UFO and one of the interesting
things that I find is that whenever
there's an unidentified flying object
people assume it's aliens and I don't
know how our rational human being could
do
because there's lots of an ident
almost every type of aircraft is
unidentified to me except for the planes
that I've flown in right the things that
I happen to know there there's all sorts
of flying objects that people are
inventing and different governments are
inventing so if I see a flying object
and I don't know what it is it seems
really silly for me to say oh it's an
alien from another galaxy it's visiting
us that seems it's fun to believe but
it's not it's not the most rational
conclusion so there's a lot of these
there's a lot of weird things coming
into play with the D with the
extra-terrestrial stuff and that the the
thumbnail for this video is this alien
supposedly alien fetus and it's just a
normal normal human fetus that's been
mummified the the skull is really
weird-looking it's got these different
chunks of bone that come together to
form this conehead skull with look it
almost looks like spikes coming off of
it and that's just because a baby's
skull forms and little growth patches
and when it's mummified it's dried out
so the brain has dried out and so it's
turned into a cone head and the the bone
plates are overlapping each other now it
looks really strange if you look at it
and all you know about biology is what
you saw on movies you would say this is
an alien and you the guy who first found
it made it but made money showing it to
people saying it was an alien and once
you know a little bit about human
anatomy especially how fetus is
developed it's super obvious that you're
looking at a human fetus but you know
it's 6 inches tall and so on but these
are things that you know like we want to
it's scary looking it's weird looking at
it it gives us this this uncanny feeling
when we look at this this mummified
fetus all of those things come into play
to make us draw these conclusions that
are not true it's it's really
interesting how that works I'm looking
again I'm looking for highlighted
questions here we're gonna do
maybe maybe three more
we're already at an hour and a half so
Tim Smith doesn't propaganda prove how
easily humans are manipulated what would
you think about that
propaganda at marketing doesn't that
prove how easily it is to manipulate us
I think it does okay I think that's a
good point that you know when I when I
hear about the algorithms on social
media sites and the algorithms are used
by advertisers that they're they're
looking at what do what do people
respond to what do people buy how can we
cover them with ads that are targeted
toward their specific things that
they're interested in I think that
there's a lot of effort on part of the
media to communicate our thinking and to
manipulate our purchases and those kinds
of things which behooves us to be well
grounded in critical thinking and taking
things with a grain of salt them and God
We Trust everyone else bring data it's
really it's really obvious until you're
being tricked by it so like if when you
watch those old beer commercials that
were on TV when I was a kid it would be
some people drinking beer and then a
bunch of girls in bikinis and they're
marketing towards men and it's super
obvious that this beer is not gonna
bring you girls and big women in bikinis
but for some reason I think it's almost
a parody of itself but there's the Axe
body spray
commercials which you're just hilarious
where I put on his his perfume and then
all these girls flock to him and it's
that's almost they just took it to
parody level but they're still kind of
they was they were still using it to
manipulate people to buy their products
and it's it's laughable when you when
you look at it but then there's all the
times where you
notice it and it really is working on
you it's working on you and Facebook
promotes that the person in your
Facebook feed that said the thing that
just drives you nuts and you have to
respond you don't you don't notice that
Facebook is manipulating you but that's
what's happening you don't it yeah it's
it's it's it's really interesting how
this how this works and when we were
kids I remember you showing us a
commercial commercials and saying what
are the tricks that people are using on
you right now in this commercial and we
would talk about him and that was super
helpful I think
well eventually helpful for me to
realize the tricks that my religion was
using on me and then but just every
other every other aspect of and that
that lesson was probably one of the most
important things you did like actively
did for me growing up that I really
remember so I appreciate that
sure anytime can you explain the Fermi
paradox I am NOT that's it's it's kind
of off topic for now the Fermi paradox
would be the one where it you know if we
haven't it if we actually haven't seen
aliens then that must mean that there's
something really bad about developing
technology like that civilizations kill
themselves I believe that's what the
Fermi paradox is but I'd have to go read
up on that again before I tried to go
into that in depth and Smith s who plays
the drums oh I do this this is actually
a whole studio of guitars and drums I
music is a hobby that I have thoughts
and John I don't know if everybody knows
that you have an album that you did high
school and yeah you need to hear John's
rendition of Folsom Prison Blues and
he's also written and a number of songs
that I think he now disowns he was quite
the musician in his time yeah yeah if
you google John Perry Folsom Prison
you'll hear you'll hear me at open mic
years ago thoughts on whether disrespect
is objective I'm not sure I totally
understand that question
does that question make sense to you it
is objective yeah I don't quite know
what that means either
yeah in that context I'm not sure what
you mean by objective I think that well
I'm gonna give you some time to respond
there because there's a lag and then
you've also got a type so are there any
final thoughts that you have for the
people well I guess my thought is that I
first of all really appreciate again
kind of the honor of being on your on
your program
I'm a retired educator now so I don't
get as many opportunities to speak about
these things or even think about them as
I used to I'm starting to learn to
fly-fish and that kind of stuff which is
a different way of getting in touch with
my with my the inner dynamics of my
psyche but I I guess my parting shot
would be if we all recognize that we are
as human beings at least most of us are
very motivated by our need for a sense
of adequacy and our desire to protect
ourselves from messages of inadequacy
were motivated by our desire to belong
and conversely motivated by a desire to
avoid situations where we don't belong
and we're motivated by our desire for
certainty and all of those are healthy
desires they can all be productive and
lead us to fulfilled wives and
successful lives but they can also
create blinders for us so that we're
we're not allowing ourselves to see lots
of other information that would be
helpful in terms of our understanding of
reality so the driving question of Who
am I in the matter of what is
influencing my thinking and and you know
what are the things that that sway me
Beth I think just really healthy to stay
aware of those things yeah we could all
use a little bit more humility in the
way we approach the world so there's my
closing thoughts cool I got a I got a
response from max make a fool
hey subjective or objective meaning is
it a matter of opinion I feel
disrespected but you might not consider
it disrespect versus the the act is
disrespectful to anyone as a fact so I
think I think I think he's talking about
well his original question was whether
disrespect is objective so I think I
guess I would say he's asking our
certain behavior is just offensive to
everyone objectively or is there are
there problems and I would say that
things are definitely most things I
would say are probably subjective which
is why if you are being offended it's
important to communicate that to other
people in a way that kind of gives them
benefit of the doubt at first if you're
in a situation - and otherwise you know
you someone can't some people can't
immediately know if they're being
offensive or disrespectful and in all
situations
what are your thoughts on that well one
of the hard things about the internet
and the way we communicate is a lot of
it is not based on relationships over
time it's may
on the right now with a faceless person
that I've never met and I'm interacting
with them
the reality is that if if you and I have
trusts we've built with each other John
over time if you know that I am
fundamentally interested in your best
interests and and you're fundamentally
interested in my best interests and we
can agree to disagree but we like each
other
we we've had experiences where we've had
some disagreements and we've gotten over
and built on and we've also had a lot of
positive experiences with each other we
started to build what I call a
relationship bank account yeah and a
strong relationship bank account with
you I can make a withdrawal in other
words I can I can have a negative
interaction with you and it's not going
to bankrupt the relationship because we
got a whole lot invested in that
relationship bank account but if I have
zero relationship bank account with you
and then I do
I challenge you in some way I challenge
your sense of certainty your sense of
belonging your sense of adequacy you're
going to immediately feel disrespected
by that and that relation and go sour
really quickly and and but one of the
problems is that we're interacting with
people all the time that we don't have
relationships with and we're not careful
about that and so that's why those those
relationships that were quickly and
people see it as a disrespectful comment
even if I didn't mean it that way if
it's a little bit in that direction
given that I they have no other
experience with me
that can go sour quick yeah yeah angry
that that's a really interesting point
the this big problem right now is that
we have so many I mean our society is so
big that you interact with a lot of
people for the first time ever and then
it's easy to offend somebody in a way
that they think you should know better
and maybe you don't
there's I've got a question related to
this and this is gonna be the last
question that we do here just because of
time but thoughts on whether being part
of more minorities makes people
less biased so is I guess as you know I
guess he's asking that if you are you
know if you belong to several minority
groups are you going to be able to see
these biases more clearly or or are you
going to be the same as someone who's
not in any minority group I don't know
if that would be a part of your area of
expertise white growth white guys yeah
it does make sense to me though I
remember I didn't France was a Mormon
missionary there for two years back when
I was 19 20 years old and I remember
somebody there talking about the French
language they said they've got a phrase
in France that essentially translates to
if knowing only one language is like
looking through the world with the only
one eye and knowing multiple languages
gives you greater perspective because
the way people express their language
the language they used to to talk about
things it's different in different
countries and so it gives you a deeper
perspective I would imagine that if you
were the part of if you were part of
several groups that were had minority
status you know say you were
socioeconomically disadvantaged and and
you were a person of color or a religion
or some other group that was in in a
minority in that you would have a richer
understanding of of what people
experience then you know especially
people of various minority groups and if
a if a new minority group you became
aware of you would probably have a
richer immediate understanding of a
number of things that they wrestle with
versus somebody who was not a member of
those Minori or that I mean that makes
sense to me - yeah I don't know that it
would automatically
make you less biased the thing that I'm
thinking about is the the Lutheran's so
I think talking about old religions is a
is a kind of a safer way to talk about
this then current dramas that are
happening the the Lutheran's were they
were rebelling against the Catholic
Church and there was a bunch of drama
between the Catholics and the Lutheran's
and then though within the Lutheran
movement there was the Anabaptist
movement which was a new religion or
they would rebaptised people and a lot
of the the Lutheran's were pretty much
divided on this because a lot of them
saw this as we just went through this
the anabaptists should not be persecuted
for their beliefs and then some people
went the extreme other way and they said
oh you want to be rebaptised i'll
rebaptised you and they started drowning
people so there's it's kind of like
people go both ways with this it went
when you've been oppressed or when you
when you've when you've had these
troubles a lot of times you're more
empathetic and more compassionate and
but there are occasions where you just
go the opposite way
and maybe it's maybe it's I don't know
what's what's driving that I think in
the case of the Anabaptist movement the
the really violent response from the
Lutheran's there was a bunch of
political things involved in it as well
but it's yeah I think there's a there's
a lot that can happen there I don't
think I don't think there's anything
automatic about this yeah you know that
makes sense I could also see that if
you're that if you are of a minority
group and you had a certain experience
then you might want to assign that same
experience to every other minority group
and that could be inaccurate but you
could be blind to the fact that you
don't understand that other minority
groups experience so so then actually
biases you in a way that is kind of
productive
yeah cool well we're going to end there
because we're almost at two hours so but
yeah thank Scott Perry dad thanks for
coming on the show this is really cool
it was my pleasure job thanks for having
me